I am I've been gone so long some of you
were forgotten Who I am but my name is
David Horowitz this is a production of
the david horowitz freedom center
briefly what happened to me as my my
foot was paralyzed I I wish I could say
it was from kicking James Carville or
Sandra Fluke but it was actually a
botched hip operation be careful when
you have them and to choose a decent
surgeon so my sciatic nerve was damaged
and that means paralysis and a lot of
pain I am on the men this is my first
public appearance since March the
operation was unable first that was
another oversight on my part and I'm
here in part because I have a new doctor
and that doctor is the chairman of the
David Horowitz Freedom Center Michael
Weiner
thank you Michael this is a an important
occasion the young man who is our
speaker today has is is transforming the
center he has two websites true through
both in Israel revolt which are much
bigger than anything the center was able
to do 15 years prior it's very exciting
if you've been up to these sites and if
you've seen the videos of Bill Whittle
and Andrew Clavin - brilliant
yeah two billion performers we have a
million and a half dollars pledged to
expand what then is doing
but it has to be matched so I hope if
there's anybody here who has whether it
doesn't matter five ten fifty $100,000
well it depends on how wealthy you are
doesn't it hundred thousand dollars can
seem like nickels and dimes to some
people but please consider seriously
helping us match these these funds and
making the center grow and that's
because the Senate does one thing that
almost nobody on the right does and that
is to call things by their right names
as Ben will be discoursing r2o today we
have a criminal in the white house
[Applause]
how do you when you have a president who
is a criminal who has utter contempt for
the Constitution violates it every day
how do you rein him in well who's the
chief law enforcement officer in the
land he's a member of the same criminal
gang so what do you do well one thing
you can do is party and so I'm going to
invite you well we're having a big party
at my home on the 26th of July I won't I
won't give the address out here on TV
because there are so many idiots on the
left oh my gosh trouble um hopefully
this won't come out till after the party
anyway but it's gonna be a western-style
party we have a DJ Joel Gilbert's Dylan
legends band is gonna play we're gonna
have pony rides for the kids and horse
rides for adults it's gonna be a lot of
fun and it's to celebrate my new book
which is about how to fight the left
which is all we really do at the center
it's gonna take no prisoners um what
else was I gonna say here oh it's worse
than having a criminal has been will
also tell you in the White House this
man is a communist a lifelong communist
and therefore his contempt for the
Constitution is not like a criminal who
doesn't like the law that he's breaking
he doesn't like the system of laws that
we have and he's determined to undo them
this is the most dangerous situation the
United States has ever faced
and we have precious few leaders at the
moment who are articulating the battle
that
needs to be articulated and fighting it
I Republicans still think this is
politics is normal it isn't so that's
why what the Freedom Center does is so
important why Ben's book is so important
and why what what he does at the center
is so important thank you
well thank you to David obviously thank
you to the center and this is the only
place on the right that that does call
things by the real name there's there's
a lot of weakness unfortunately on the
right that weakness on the right has led
to an unending series of leftist
victories over the last 80 years in this
country which has led to a growth of
government that now puts us on the verge
of what can only be termed an executive
tyranny an executive dictatorship a
dictatorship that we get to elect every
four years but then we were supposed to
sit back and watch as our rights are
trampled over last week President Obama
told a crowd in Minneapolis quote he was
talking about the Republicans of course
he's talking about the D Congress he
said they don't do anything except
blocked me and and call me names because
this is the most powerful man on earth
whining and he also said they don't do
anything except block me and then dick
Durbin he was talking about specifically
about immigration dick Durbin last week
added that because these folks only
block him and call him names President
Obama would quote borrow the power that
is needed to solve the problems of
immigration you borrow it right sort of
like you borrow your neighbor's cup of
sugar except you never give back the cup
of sugar because you've used it and when
when power is borrowed it is never
restored that's the point of borrowing
power in the first place
President Obama is always very happy to
borrow power because as David mentioned
the left is fundamentally opposed to the
Constitution of the United States they
are fundamentally opposed to the basic
founding concept of American freedom and
liberty they seek to tear it down
I disagree slightly with David in terms
of the president being a communist
president David knows communism
significantly better than I do so I'll
defer to his definition of communism but
he in my view the president is is beyond
that he is a nihilist he wants to tear
down the system almost solely for the
sake of tearing down the system it's not
even about establishing equality or
establishing a basic standard of rights
or debate or to avoid poverty
it's about tearing down the system
purely and simply now that there folks
on the Left who see the Constitution of
the United States is a real obstacle
these folks include people who sit on
the Supreme Court of the United
Ruth Bader Ginsburg said not long ago
she said quote I would not look to the
US Constitution if I were drafting a
constitution in the year 2012 I might
look at the Constitution of South Africa
she said that was a deliberate attempt
to have a fundamental instrument of
government that embraced basic human
rights had an independent judiciary it
really is I think a great piece of work
that was done much more recent than the
US Constitution which is of course why
South Africa is such a thriving and
wonderful in free country today the
South African Constitution contains the
following provision section 26 of that
Constitution contains the right to
housing including the right to due
process with regard to court-ordered
eviction and demolition section 27
includes the rights to food water health
care and social assistance which the
state must progressively realize within
the limits of its resources this is the
sort of Constitution that the left wants
a constitution in which the government
guarantees you stuff and violates your
rights in order to guarantee you those
things and if they don't deliver on that
promise well you know they can't win
them all but the bottom line is that
they will pretend to guarantee you these
things how do we know that they're just
pretending because there have been other
constitutions in the past that contain
similar provisions for example there was
a constitution in the recent prat in the
recent past that suggested quote the
distribution and usage of real estate
should be supervised by the state in
order to prevent abuse and in order to
strive to secure healthy housing to all
families especially those with many
children in order to maintain health and
the ability to work in order to protect
motherhood and to prevent economic
consequences of age weakness and to
protect against the vicissitudes of life
the state establishes a comprehensive
system of insurances this particular
Constitution also said that the state
should transfer economic enterprises
suited for nationalization into common
property if the regulations for
expropriation are obeyed and if
compensation is not violated I'm
speaking of course of the vimana
Constitution it guaranteed all of these
rights the Chinese Constitution
similarly guarantees for example the
rights of free speech and the rights of
freedom of the press in other words
these are all paper documents the
American Constitution is to and the only
people standing between us and the great
ma of government that seeks to turn us
up and spit us out is be the will of the
American people
stop this and to stand up for liberty
and all the guarantees of people who say
that this is alarmist to talk in these
sorts of terms this is I think one of
the great myths no MERS that we've
experienced in modern history
we've bought our own propaganda with
regard to folks like Hitler in the sense
that yes Hitler was evil but Hitler
didn't come in with the jackboots Hitler
came in and he did it softly if you read
Hitler's speech for example right before
the enabling act right he was arguing
for the enabling act in 1933 right after
the rest and fire and and Hitler when he
argued for the Enabling Act which was
enacted essentially ended all civil
rights in Germany and handed unilateral
power over to the Chancellor namely
Hitler he actually said this is the
direct quote the government will make
use of these powers only insofar as they
are essential for carrying out vitally
necessary measures he's going to borrow
the power right the existence if neither
the Red Stag nor the rats rot is
endangered the position and rights of
the ref president remain inviolate it
will always be the first and foremost
task of the government to bring about
inner consensus with his aims says the
rights of churches will not be curtailed
their position beezly the state will not
be altered the number of cases when
there'll be an internal necessity you
know like people here that will have to
deal with that'll be really limited that
is what he said in 1933 and of course
his opponent who's got named otto bells
who is from the Social Democratic Party
he protested he said never in the
history of the German Reichstag has
control over public affairs vested in
the elected representatives of the
people been eliminated to this extent
and what's amazing about this particular
exchange that the the presidents of the
Reichstag at that time was Hermann
Goering who's obviously one of Hitler's
emissaries his right-hand man and he
actually got up in the middle of the
speech and he's shouting who's the head
of the legislature he shouted at the
head of the of the Social Democratic
Party which was the opposition party he
shouted at them stop talking and listen
to Hitler now the Chancellor is getting
even he was getting up he's rooting for
Hitler in the middle of this of this
legislative discussion sort of like
obviously there are differences but on a
systemic level sort of like the modern
Democratic Party sort of like members of
the Democratic Party who have decided
that they are going to forego their
legislative duty as a member of the
legislative branch to check the
executive in other words the goal is
more important than the system the goal
is more important than this
now the Constitution was established
it's not a value neutral Constitution
our Constitution was established in
order to embody certain basic values in
order to protect certain basic value
thread was established in order to
protect certain inalienable rights we
celebrated this a few days ago although
the fact is that if you read the current
list if you read the list written in
1776 of the violations of the king many
of them pale in comparison to the sorts
of violations of Rights that we see
today and when it talks about the
multiplicity of officers that have been
sick de pond the people of the United
States for example in the Declaration of
Independence he's talking about a few
tax officials and he was not talking
about the IRS specifically targeting
particular groups at the behest of the
President of the United States the
Constitution of the United States was
specifically designed though to preserve
certain values to embody certain
fundamental beliefs about the nature of
humanity so for example it was it was
supposed to create a check against the
nature of mankind this is why the
founders truly believed you needed
balance you need an interest to
counterbalance interest the nature of
mankind dictated that men were capable
of great evil and men were capable of
great good but no man could be trusted
with ultimate power because men were
capable of great evil which is of course
exactly what Madison said in Federalist
51 he said you know men are not angels
if they were angels no government would
be necessary and if there were Devils no
governments it should suffice
basically we aren't were human beings
and that's why we need interest to
counteract interest but this is not the
view of a President Obama and people
like him in their view people who are
not President Obama are Devils and he is
an angel in his view and the views of
members of this administration people
who work for the government are by
necessity good they're a self self
selected group of people who are only
there for the best all the rest of us
are there for the worst we're there for
self-interest evil self-interest is why
you see President Obama and his wife go
around to the rest of the country and
say on a repeated basis that if you
really want to do good for the country
don't go into private sector don't start
a business give back to them go into
public service with the cushy government
pension and a nice rate of pay and an
arbitration process if you should happen
to rape somebody but if you really want
to serve the public what you want to do
is get into the business of government
because that makes you a fundamentally
better human being and therefore because
you are now in this position government
should have all
the power in the country the
Constitution was established on the
basis that natural rights come from God
not from government and that as soon as
government violates those natural rights
which come from God you have a right to
stand up to the government and yet we
are one vote away in this country one
vote from religious rights in the
country being finished
and I mean that very seriously as an
Orthodox Jew it's something I take very
seriously if the Hobby Lobby case goes
the other way and remember was a 5-4
vote we are talking about the ability of
the government of the United States to
force religious people in their daily
lives to violate their own religious
precepts precisely the opposite of what
the First Amendment was supposed to
guarantee the founders never would have
contemplated this for the founders there
was no conflict whatsoever between the
idea that church was not supposed to in
fact state and the idea that state was
not supposed to crush church eskas
government was supposed to be small so
the idea that government was ever going
to infringe on American liberties so far
as a religious practice that was
unthinkable to the founders were there
it's where we are right the Constitution
was established in order to establish
the basic principles that these rights
cannot be taken away from you that the
government cannot arbitrarily apply the
law the government can't for example
leave the border wide open in order to
incentivize tens of thousands of illegal
immigrant children to cross it and then
decide all the sudden to apply the law
when busing those kids to me orietta and
the people who are telling the federal
government that they ought to enforce
the border become the real criminals in
this administration so what do you do
when you're faced with a group of folks
who fundamentally are criminals because
in order to get to what they want they
have to tear down the Constitution and
because the Constitution is a system
they have to violate the system they
have to destroy the system they have to
tear it out by the roots you have to
engage in wildly law-breaking activity
and you need everybody to look the other
way those are the two things that need
to happen in order to achieve what we
are looking at right now which puts us
on the verge of an executive tyranny
meaning that the President of the United
States can do damn well what he pleases
and nobody can stop him and we are now
in that position and I said this on Sean
Hannity show the other night is that the
President of the United States could
literally strangle you and might want to
right he could literally strangle you on
this stage and the American people could
do nothing about it because under they
because the
institution of the United States
provided is the remedy for that
impeachment well Harry Reid doesn't like
Sean Hannity very much so if the
president were to strangle Sean Hannity
on a stage then the President of the
United States would then be subject to
the whims of Eric Holder and Harry Reid
which means of course that nothing would
ever happen so requires two things one a
president who is willing to destroy all
of the bounds on his own power to burst
out to burst forth and sort of like as
he puts it a grizzly bear and the
president the other week said that he
the bear is loose talking about the bear
is loose he's going to do precisely what
he wants and he needs an American people
that his compliance and a legislative
body that is willing to hand him that
power and do nothing about it and
fortunately for this particular
president that's exactly what he has and
this is a criminal presidency it's
important that folks understand this is
why you know in my new book the People
vs Barack Obama in that book I make the
case this is a criminal presidency
specifically because we cannot see this
presidency as just more politics this is
not just more politics what we are
watching has nothing to do with politics
this has to do with criminal violations
if President Obama or in the private
sector he would be in prison Eric Holder
would be in prison Kathleen Sebelius
would be in prison Lois Lerner would be
in prison everybody who is working at
ATF turn fast and furious would be in
prison all of these folks would be in
prison the safest place to be a criminal
in American society today is in the
government that is the safest place to
be a criminal if you're looking to steal
from somebody if you're looking to harm
somebody if you're looking to kill
somebody if you're looking to leave for
people without guns in terrorists part
of the world and watch them die the
safest place to do that and then run for
president is in the government so here
are just a few of the crimes that this
administration has pursued in
furtherance of its goal which is of
course to destroy the Constitution and
to destroy the American system as we
know it and this all sounds alarmist to
folks haven't left exhale this is
alarmist stuff the president can't do
anything that he wants well then why are
you arguing for him to be able to do
anything that he wants really the
probably what exactly have you heard
folks on the Left say you know the
president has gone too far this time
anything will they ever say that of
course not george w bush went too far
because he was on the other side of the
aisle but president obama he can never
go far enough and in fact we should work
to ensure that
that he continues to go further it was a
man the president made an amazing
statement the other day the President of
the United States actually said the
other day he was talking about the the
intransigence the supposed intransigence
of Congress and he said you know
Congress won't work with me I will
continue to act - to do whatever is
necessary he said if the Republicans
don't like it if they don't like it they
can join me so these are the two choices
in America right now bow to the
dictatorship or bow to the dictatorship
all right these are the two choices so
here are just some of the crimes that
this administration has taken part in
espionage but you're not allowed to give
money or guns to terrorist groups as
Hamas how that's working out for them
because the presidents of the United
States continues to sign four hundred
and forty million dollars worth of money
over to the Palestinian Authority unity
government which includes Hamas and
Islamic Jihad State Department sponsored
terrorist organizations and the State
Department has sided with Hamas with the
Palestinian Authority with Islamic Jihad
called on Israel for restraint against
terrorist groups that kidnap young
Jewish boys and then proceeded to murder
them they're doing this now on the basis
of this Palestinian kid who tragically
was killed
by Jewish extremists there is a vast
difference between the two sides there
are no streets going to be named after
these Jewish pathetic pieces of human
refuse who engaged in this conduct
they're going to be prosecuted to the
full extent of the law every Jew who
watched what happened on Sunday when
this arrest took place and all this came
out felt sick to his stomach they felt
like vomiting and never stopped vomiting
that was not true on the other side when
these three Jewish boys were killed
Hamas was celebrating they ran ads in
their newspapers showing these three
Jewish boys as dead rats okay there is a
vast difference between the two sides
but of course this administration is
three yeah this administration is not
interested in in any way in cracking
down on terrorism they're interested in
funding terrorism we've now reversed
sides in the war on terror everybody who
we are fighting has at one point or
another received American money or guns
including Isis right who are now
fighting in Iraq and both sides of that
we're now funding right Iran we've
relieved the sanctions on so they're
taking over the southern half of Iraq
and Isis is taking over the northern
half of Iraq because we funded their
allies in the war against Bashar Assad
who it turns out we're now going to fund
to fight Isis so we are now on every
side of every issue except the right
side
which in that arena of the world is
Israel in Israel alone that test be a
nosh and it's a violation of the arms
Export Control Act to boot the arms
Export Control Act suggest I cannot
funnel if I were to funnel a gun to Isis
I'd be arrested if President Obama does
it that's just American foreign policy
involuntary manslaughter right the basic
case of involuntary manslaughter and the
lawyer so the basic case for involuntary
manslaughter is a three prong test right
somebody died number one somebody died
as a result of reckless action number
two number three the person who took
that reckless action knew it was
reckless and could result in death at
the time those are the three elements of
involuntary manslaughter Benghazi anyone
leaving no security anywhere in the
vicinity in an area where we were
running guns to Syria through Turkey in
an area where the New York Times had
reported literally the year before that
the entire town was run by Ansar
al-sharia and surprise surprise Ansar
al-sharia was behind the terrorist
attack to kill Chris Stevens and three
other Americans who's responsible for
that Hillary Clinton's responsible for
that she's guilty of involuntary
manslaughter
she shouldn't be worried about whether
she goes to the White House she should
be worried about whether she goes to the
big house unfortunately we have an
attorney general who would never
prosecute anyone for these sorts of
violations because he too is a criminal
and he too is guilty of involuntary
manslaughter as it turns out he greenlit
the fast and furious program turns out
that you might think that running guns
to Mexican drug cartels with no tags in
them by the way there are no electronic
monitors on these guns it was it was
widely known inside ATF that when you
run guns to the Mexican drug cartels the
only place they're gonna show up so that
we can back-channel them backtrack them
and figure out where they were is that
crime scenes this was explicitly known
at the ATF at the time you might think
that's reckless you might think that
that might result in homicide like the
killing of a Border Patrol agent perhaps
and you might be the head of the DOJ and
if you're involved in this you were
probably promoted because nobody who's
responsible for fast and furious has
gone to jail nobody to and nobody's
really even been fired
how about violation of Internal Revenue
laws if you or I were to leverage the
IRS to crack down on particular folks we
would be put in jail that's a violation
of the Internal Revenue Code itself 26
US Code 7212
people who are following it's also
violation for for politicians and firfer
politically motivated bureaucrats to get
involved in this is violation of the
Hatch Act right the Hatch Act prohibits
bureaucrats from getting involved in
political situations like this in
targeting political opponents it's a
violation of law but it's a phony
scandal according to the President of
the United States
Yoda how corrupt and criminal and nasty
this administration is John Eastman runs
the National Organization for Marriage
I'm sure some of you know of John John's
National Organization for Marriage is
obviously a pro traditional marriage
organization this administration is anti
traditional marriage and so the IRS
leaked the confidential tax information
including donor information about the
National Organization for Marriage which
is a 501 C 3 which means their tax tone
that their donors are confidential they
leaked their entire donor list to the
Human Rights Campaign which is a gay
advocacy group now they use the
middleman in order to do this John's
group National Organization for Marriage
sued the IRS the IRS acknowledged that
they had in fact leaked this material
and signed over 50,000 of your tax
dollars to the National Organization for
Marriage now what John did is John said
okay fine you know we'd like to find out
who particularly at the IRS did this
let's trace this back up the chain who
decided that it would be a great idea to
hand over confidential tax information
to political opponents right who decided
that would be a great idea so they said
to Eric Holder why don't you prosecute
the middleman right who had received the
confidential tax information and
distribute it in violation of law why
don't you prosecute americolor said no
one will be prosecuted for this no one
will be prosecuted for this so John said
okay fine you're not gonna prosecute him
give him immunity because this guy was
pleading the fifth
you can only plead the fifth that there
is a threat of criminal prosecution or
you can't plead the fifth
if I was cheating on my wife I can't
just say I plead the fifth that has no
relevance you're not threatened to
criminally prosecute me the fifth
amendment is only available in
situations in which you do not have
immunity so John said to Eric Holder go
ahead give this guy immunity then we can
sue the IRS we can subpoena him and we
can force him to answer questions about
where he got this material and Eric
Holder said I will not give him immunity
so in other words he won't prosecute the
guy to get the information and he won't
get immunity he won't give immunity so
the guys
the guy would give up the information
this is the height of criminality and
it's so blatant and yet have you has
anybody outside this room ever heard of
the National Organization for Marriage
can you imagine if the end of a CP had
tsuj Bush's IRS and Bush's IRS said yeah
you know what we discriminated against
you here's the $50,000 settlement you
think that might lead the news for a few
nights but for the Obama administration
it will not even make the back page of
the New York Times
how about unauthorized disclosure of
information you're not allowed to leaked
confidential national security
information and yet this administration
has done that repeatedly this is this
administration has done four separate
times with regard to Israeli national
security information sunk Israel's
ability to strike Iran Israel was
supposed to use an airbase in Azerbaijan
to strike Iran that was leaked by the
Defense Department to the New York Times
Israel was supposed to work with the
Saudis who Saudi airspace to strike Iran
that was leaked by the Defense
Department to the New York Times Israel
was behind stucks and us that was leaked
by the Defense Department to the
Washington Post and Israel was working
on agreements with particular groups to
go in and try and decapitate some of the
heads of the nuclear program that was
also leaked by the Defense Department's
of The Washington Post but it's not just
Israeli national security information
that's being leaked you know how we all
knew that President Obama had his kill
list no Rand Paul has been very big on
President Obama has his kill list
American citizens abroad who he just
decides we can kill which by the way is
regardless of what you think of the
killing of Anwar al-awlaki and I'm fine
with it he's a terrorist he deserved to
die the possibility that we now live in
a country where the president can
determine based on which side of the bed
he woke up this morning whether to hit
somebody with a drone or trade them for
five Taliban terrorists is frightening
that should be frightening hippo
Bergdahl was no friend to the United
States according to most reports and yet
he was an American citizen who had to be
brought home just in time for the
president to quash the VA scandal they
had to be brought home at the cost of
five Taliban top Taliban officials
because he was an American citizen he
had to be brought home his name happened
to be Anwar he'd be dead from a drone
strike in Yemen so the president
literally I mean that is if there's
anything that's that speaks to
dictatorial power it is the ability of
the President to unilaterally declare
who is an American citizen and who is
not an American citizen for the purposes
of hitting them with a drone or trading
terrorists for them deprivation of
rights under color of law
the fact is that what the Obama
administration has done as far as the
mining of metadata and I'm a hawk on
national security is far beyond the
scope of the Patriot Act far beyond the
scope of the Patriot Act representative
Sensenbrenner has said as much that
Sensenbrenner who wrote the Patriot Act
said if I had ever conceived that the
Patriot Act would be this widely applied
by the President of the United States to
be checking our Gmail's and our G chats
and our metadata on our phones I never
would have signed off on the thing this
is a violation of our rights under color
of law
bribery obviously is rampant within this
administration the president has paid
off unions the president has paid off
various political allies with
ambassadorships he's paid them off with
cash to their companies in some of
statistics on bribery from this
administration are just stunning overall
the Washington Post has reported 3.9
billion dollars in federal grants and
financing flow to 21 companies backed by
firms with connections to five Obama
administration staffers and advisers
according to Peter Schweitzer the Obama
administration's 20 billion dollars in
green technology loans contained 16
billion dollars so four out of five
dollars for the for the green technology
loans went to companies related to
President Obama or his cronies bribery
is rampant within this administration
and then of course there's obstruction
of justice in which the federal
government gets involved in cases it has
no business in cases like for example
the george zimmerman case in florida in
which the DOJ inserted its thumb on the
scales of justice and attempted to
convict george zimmerman before the
evidence was even in or the case of
Gerald womp in the inspector general who
is fired when he investigated President
Obama's friend in Sacramento the mayor
of Kevin Johnson he was fired on
ceremoniously or the case of the new
Black Panthers in which the Department
of Justice decided just wasn't
worthwhile checking out people waving
batons outside of polling places because
they happen to be black but if you want
to check an ID of a black person then
you're a racist so what we have here
obviously obviously at this point is a
criminal administration we're seeing it
every day the only problem with the book
is I had to stop writing at at some
point
while we're watching on the southern
border obviously is is in my opinion the
single most grave threat to national
security that we have seen over the
course of this presidency and that's
saying a hell of a lot considering we
have a president who just surrendered a
rock to terrorists has put Israel in
mortal danger and signed a nuclear deal
with Iran but we are watching on our
southern border is a threat to the very
existence of the United States and it is
specifically there are people who are
out there folks on the left and it's
incredible the skewed view of folks on
the left truly astonishing somebody
wrote a column at USA Today saying is
this Obama's Katrina is Obama's Katrina
no it's not Obama's Katrina that was a
hurricane that was an act of God it just
shows the the hatred for President Bush
on folks on the left it is not even
wildly comparable in your in your worst
imagination it's not comparable
President Obama created this hurricane
the year before Obama took office there
were 6,000 illegal immigrant miners who
attempted to cross the border this year
they're gonna be close to a hundred
thousand that doesn't just magically
happen President Obama who's going out
there now saying well I didn't incentive
I don't know where the where they
getting this crazy idea where are they
getting this insane idea that they
should come across the border
no get they're getting this crazy idea
from the fact that the President of the
United States has vowed not to deport
anyone between the ages of 16 and 30 in
the country illegally from the fact that
the President of the United States sued
the state of Arizona for enforcing
federal immigration law and from the
fact that the President of the United
States has stood behind every effort by
major cities including Los Angeles to
become sanctuary cities just yesterday
the LAPD announced they wouldn't even
admit requests from ice to hold criminal
illegal aliens 48 extra hours so we
could find out if they were eligible for
deportation the mayor of Eric Garcetti
said that what was the Obama
administration's response dead silence
but Jan Brewer says we'd like to find
out if people are illegal immigrants and
the President of the United States Sue's
her
I wonder where these illegal immigrants
got this idea I wonder and so the
question becomes what do we do because
this president is a criminal and and the
criminality is not going to end with him
okay what we're watching here this idea
that the President of the United States
is going to end his tenure and then we
will move on into
if Hillary Clinton is your idea of a
non-criminal in the White House I'd like
to see her idea of a criminal in the
White House if you are she hasn't
declared her candidacy yet obviously if
but suffice it to say would the problem
we have here is a systemic one because
the the founders wanted the founders
were desperate for a check on the on the
executive branch the legislature will
not do it the legislature is not
interested in doing it the legislature
is interested in getting reelected and
to do that they just hand all their
power over to a bunch of unelected
bureaucrats unelected regulators because
that way if something goes wrong they
blame the executive branch and if
something goes right they take credit
meanwhile the Supreme Court of the
United States has certainly no check and
balance on the executive branch anybody
who read the Hobby Lobby case as a check
on the executive branch is missing the
point that we are one vote away from it
not being and also missing the point
that Hobby Lobby could have established
a broad mandate in favor of religious
freedom and neglected to do so is a very
narrowly tailored decision the same
thing was true of the NRA of the the
NLRB the National Labor Relations Board
decision that happened the week before
right that particular decision was
portrayed by the press as a slap against
the Obama administration it absolutely
was not as Justice Scalia explained in
his concurrence it instead set up a
process whereby any time Congress takes
a vacation more than 10 days the
President of the United States can
appoint anybody he wants that's in the
decision the states would have been the
normal check on the federal government
this is what the founders thought this
is why the founders believed that the
Constitution was a compact not only of
the people but over the states this is
what it says in the Federalist Papers it
says ok well the federal government will
never get too big as the states won't
stand for it well that's been largely
overthrown because of the nasty legacy
of states rights and what that has
historically meant it doesn't discredit
the concept of states rights which needs
to come back in a very major way in
order to preserve freedom in the United
States and we need to disconnect the
nasty history of states rights from the
fundamentally good principle of states
rights but that has proved not to be
enough of a check the final check
unfortunately unfortunately is us and
we're seeing that and what we're seeing
in Marietta is that the buses are
turning around what we're seeing is that
the American people don't understand a
fundamental truth and when they do
understand it they tend to turn to our
sighs the American people do not
understand a fundamental truth that
fundamental truth is that every
government law every government
regulation is backed by a gun every one
of them in the end the EPA regulations
on how much water you use in your toilet
if you don't use the proper amount of
water in your toilet the first thing
they will do is they will send you a
fine if you refuse to pay the fine they
will put a lien on your property if your
paper used to pay the lane they will
send an agent with a gun to your house
to arrest you and if you're resist
they'll shoot you
every government law is backed by point
of gun and now if Americans realize this
if it occurred to them that this was the
truth it might be a little bit more
careful about what exactly they decided
to give people the power to do with a
gun
now the left has this meme that folks on
the right love guns we love guns you're
right we do love guns for self-defense
there's only one group in America that
loves guns more than folks on the right
folks on the left you want to use the
government gun in order to violate the
rights of people on the right they love
guns they just don't want us to have so
for the final barrier between what
really is a great American past and a
tremendously awful American future then
the question becomes what do we do I've
suggested in the book that we can pass a
law that would allow us to sue the Obama
administration sue the executive branch
hold them up in court that would do
something you've heard you've heard
people like Andy McCarthy push for
impeachment Sarah Palin today pushed for
impeachment only one problem in the
grand history of the United States 19
total impeachments in the house eight
total convictions in the Senate so I
don't think getting rid of one executive
official once every 30 years is probably
gonna do it in the end it's gonna come
down to unfortunately and fortunately
convincing people it's gonna come down
to making people understand these
fundamental concepts which is why what
we're doing at the center is so
important which is why the information
that we propagate is so important
because the media is of course the great
the great lie machine on behalf of the
executive tyranny the press is more than
happy to watch the president violate
American freedoms so long as he's on
their side and so we're gonna have to
step up we're gonna have to call things
by the right name we're gonna have to
tell the truth we're gonna have to go
into communities we never thought we
were gonna have to go into he saw today
that the Republican National Committee
decided that it would be a great idea
to hold the convention in Cleveland
which if it's not good enough for LeBron
it's not good enough for the four
conservatives but they decide to hold it
in Cleveland Republicans need to get out
of the realm of this is politics as
usual
and they need to get into the realm of
we are fighting against its iourney and
unless we convince enough people to
fight that tyranny we are we are going
to lose what they should do what
conservatives should do Republican not
republic doesn't matter what
conservatives really truly should do is
they should hold the convention in
Detroit in downtown Detroit I'm talking
like the worst part of Detroit and what
they should do is they should buy up one
of those horrific horror show looking
old buildings you know that looks like
comes straight off the set of a zombie
movie they should buy it up they should
refurbish the inside and the entire
speech by whoever the nominee is the
entire speech should just be a long shot
of the surroundings in the city of
Detroit and they should say this is what
Democrats do this is what the left does
[Applause]
and more than that the left will put a
gun to your head in order to achieve
this once Americans understand that the
destructive agenda of the left is not
just another political agenda it's
something that is violated of basic
human freedoms once they understand that
government is not the source of rice God
is the source of Rights we need to go
back to foundational principles in other
words all these things used to be
assumed we can't assume them anymore the
American people are ignorant the
American people have been trained by 40
hours a week of public education in 40
hours a week of television that we need
a big man a great leader to lead us to
prosperity and freedom we're going to
need to fight back against that on every
available front we don't have time to
pick which front we fight back against
because they're pushing on every
available front so I know this is all
depressing I know this is all the kind
of stuff that makes you want to jump in
the bathtub and toss a toaster in with
you I know I've been there but when you
decide to unplug the toaster it's time
for us to stop with the candlelight
vigils it's time for us to stop with the
prayer sessions it's time for us to stop
with the hand wringing and the hopes
that may be there on one day be a
politician on the right we'll just
embody our values and say just row just
like Reagan and it's time for us to
realize that in the words of a famous
would-be dictator
we are the people we've been waiting for
thanks so much
[Applause]
because c-span is taping if anyone has a
question they need to line up here at
the microphone so if anyone has a
question for Ben please come up and ask
yeah sure
let's do it yeah come up to the mic if
you
sorry notes of schlep Ben in addition to
impeachment and the political
ramifications of that House of
Representatives has the power of the
purse yes yeah the power the House of
Representatives should be and this is
what they should be they should been
doing this all along I recommended this
to the House leadership which of course
they ignored the the House of
Representatives should not be doing what
Ted Cruz suggested and they should also
not be funding these things but the
House of Representatives should be doing
is they should pass single measure bills
one page long on each part of the
federal government fund the government
individually and singly No More omnibus
packages omnibus packages are a way to
hide crap because here's the argument
that ends up happening it's exactly the
argument that Cruz was having with his
fellow Republicans in the Senate as well
as with as with Democrats he was saying
basically look you've created this
massive sandwich and in the middle of
this is a turd okay I don't like turd
sandwiches I don't want the sandwich and
Democrats are saying yeah but we have to
eat right well how about this how about
instead of that we just separate the
sandwich well pass a bill for bread and
then we'll pass a bill for lettuce and
then we'll pass a bill for bacon if
you're not Jewish and we'll pass all
these we'll pass a wide variety of bills
singly funding each element of the
government and then when we're all done
doing that we will leave out certain
things that we don't want to fund right
let let the Democrats Stonewall a bill
you specifically fund a particular
element of the Defense Department let
them hold that up and then blast that
out why are they standing against our
soldiers in the field which they would
do by the way why are they standing
against children if you're trying to
fund particular aspects of education
fund everything singly that's the
easiest way to defund not these not
these climactic you know these climatic
battles were supposed to have every
three months where it would is it the
debt ceiling do we hold that up to hell
but no do it the way that it was
supposed to be done under the
Constitution of the United States
spending and revenue originated in
House pass each bill singly pass each
bill to pages at a time so all of us can
understand it we don't have to look
through eight feet of regulations thanks
why can't I get a group to impeach the
president even though he's going the
group will lose you will get publicity
everything that you've said will be out
in the press it'll be on the radio to be
on the television this is something you
can't buy this kind of you just can't
buy it okay we need to understand two
fundamental principles going into any
talk of impeachment
the first fundamental principle is that
obviously he's not going to be convicted
in the Senate we know that right he's
not going anywhere and and beyond that
even if he were then we'd get Joe Biden
who I know we all dismiss as as what he
is which is a man of a very little brain
but he is but he is also a hardcore
ideologue and so it'd be suggestion it
turns out that even stupid presidents
can do an enormous amount of damage so
leave that aside for a second the other
the other truth and this is what we do a
truth revolt is that the media will
completely destroy it the media will
completely destroy it the same way that
they destroyed Kenneth Starr in order to
protect their beloved Clinton the same
way they're going to destroy these
protesters in Marietta the what we need
to focus on before we even get to that
is winning back the hearts and minds of
the American people because the way this
is going to come off and you know what
are the media narrative is going on this
and you can predict it and this is not
me agreeing with the media narrative
obviously it's false it's a lie but this
is what the media does that what they
will do is they will state that the only
reason to impeach Barack Obama who has
committed no crime of course which is
what they'll say the only reason is
because he's a black guy and we're all a
bunch of racists and so therefore it
would it would it would be a backfire I
am not focused as much as I say that
Obama's a criminal
there are lots of criminals there are
lots of them right they're staffed up in
the DOJ they're stacked up in the EPA
they're stacked up in the IRS they're
stacked up in every executive branch of
government and every executive agency by
the way has its own SWAT team so the the
all the criminals are in the government
nail guns the the solution is not to get
rid of one guy the solution is to defund
all these various parts of the
government if we're gonna do something
in the house let's do that cuz that's
actually achievable and then the
solution
is to work on convincing the American
people that it's actually worthwhile
being an American because right now we
don't have a battle in this country
between one ideology that's American and
another that's quasi American we have
one that's American and we have one that
is absolutely and utterly foreign and
antithetical to American ideals my
question is I think most of us know that
those all those emails that they claim
that they've been destroyed or crashed I
I believe in my heart that they will
eventually be found I I believe that
they've been backed up they're probably
backed up at the NSA
I'm sure yeah the question is when's the
last time you lost your emails you took
a drill to your computer to get him out
of great so they did they drilled a hole
through the Lois Lerner's hard drive
legitimate later when she said her come
here was broken into a drill and drill a
hole directly from her hard drive
exactly well there see they're gonna be
exposed and we're gonna learn about them
and once we learn that they're tied to
the White House directly my question to
you is do you think that will be enough
to be the straw that breaks the camel's
back that some extreme action could be
taken to remove this man from office
well I think that again this is again
the impeachment question and a different
guys I don't think that there's gonna be
anything that encourages Democrats to
impeach their own president it's not
going to happen the what we are what we
we should be focused on is the portrayal
of folks who are criminals so that's why
I think it's important to to speak of
them as criminals and it's important to
recognize the criminality and the
absolute evil of so many folks in the
executive branch because it is evil to
violate the rights of other people as
far as the IRS scandal I actually do not
believe that the emails will be found I
believe that if they are found I don't
think there will be a smoking gun
because Barack Obama is a lawyer and all
the lawyers know the fundamental rule of
committing a criminal act don't put it
in writing
I highly doubt you're ever going to find
an email directly from Barack Obama to
Lois Lerner saying you know be awesome
if you just went after the Tea Party
Patriots here I really don't think that
you're gonna dig that up and you don't
need to I mean that's what's so insane
in this country you don't need to do
that this is what the Racketeer
Influenced and Corrupt Organizations Act
the RICO Act was created in 1970 to go
after the Mafia the premise of that Act
was that it was very difficult to tie
the heads of the Mafia the Don Corleone
figures from the to the luca brasi
figures because there was never a direct
chain
command there's never a direct order so
they created Rico to say okay it's
obvious that you wanted this person to
be killed
you're obviously conspiracy and so now
we're gonna drag you all into court
together that's what the executive
branch is it is a mafioso organization
the President of the United States never
needs to say the Lois Lerner Target 501
C 4 is on the other side of the aisle
all he has to do is make a bunch of
speeches about how citizens united is
evil and terrible and wouldn't it be
great if somebody did this and a bunch
of senators on the Democrat side of the
aisle need to send a letter which is
what they did to the IRS saying please
target some Tea Party groups and
magically voila Tea Party groups
targeted and then of course you have
people running to the microphones to
declare it a phony scandal here's the
problem the media has such utter control
over the narrative in this country and
this is why we're going to you know I've
been begging folks they're their folks
on the right and they will drop 400
million dollars on crappy ads in
far-flung areas of Virginia for Mitt
Romney right then nobody will ever say
those four hundred dollars could buy a
network I mean honest to god for a
couple billion dollars you could buy NBC
right if we're actually going to do this
then let's do it right let's get into
the business of taking over the things
people watch it's amazing I mean what we
on the right are we're acting like it's
still 1790 and now it's time for us to
print up and distribute a bunch of
pamphlets pamphlets are great okay they
are they're wonderful but it turns out
that most people my age have never read
a pamphlet most people my age don't even
know what a pamphlet is it's some sort
of a book what is it right pamphlets are
important they really are because
they're there they get people who are
the people who actually have money to
read about the situation they get people
to distribute but you really want to do
something why don't you go to where the
crowd is we're such funny nutty's over
on the right that we were lecturing
young people about what we wish they
liked what we wish they watched what we
wish they did with their free time
instead of saying oh well what you
actually do with your free time is not
study Hayek well shocker
what do you actually do with your free
time oh it turns out that you you watch
NBC it turns out that you watch CBS or
ABC it turns out that you that you go to
websites like BuzzFeed instead of going
where the crowd is we're standing out
and on the street corner with the signs
saying the end is near and then we
expect everybody to sort of resonate
that's not the way that it works if
we're gonna spend our money let's spend
our money smart let's put our money
where it counts and let's stop worrying
about local TV ads it by the way
everybody my age TiVoed through there's
this invention it's called TiVo you go
through the commercials it's magic
everybody here understands you
completely it appears as though pretty
much the fixes in the low information
voters are not us or most of our friends
although we do have these friends and so
that's bad move on your part if you do
but continue point one is how do we
reach the low information populace when
we can't get around that the media and
we can't get the information out and for
those of us who have friends who are low
information voting Democrats who think
they're Democrats because they don't
understand what it means now what in a
sentence search this is the right
question this is totally the right
question right the right question is not
what we do about Obama particularly the
question is not what do we do about the
criminality of this particular
administration the question is how do we
reach people how do we talk to them on a
level that they understand and believe
it or not me citing the arms Export
Control Act is not going to do a lot of
good with people my age you don't know
what that that arms are not those things
that jillian Barberie has on her body
the the the answer is actually nobody's
spelled this out better than then my
mentor David Horowitz nobody has spelled
this out better you have to speak the
language of morality
you must speak the language of morality
the left wins because nobody on the left
knows anything about politics they know
you're evil that's it they know you're a
racist sexist pig at homophobe you hates
the poor right that's what they know
about you and it's not they think that
about you they know that about you deep
down they know all these evil things
about you which is why Thanksgiving
dinners are always so awkward if you're
unfortunate to have Jewish relatives or
or you have friends on the Left which
are the exact same focus group the
the the answer to all of this is to
speak in the language of morality this
is why I never say the government
compels people to do stuff the
government does not compel people to do
stuff the government compels people to
do stuff that point of gun why do I say
that cuz leftists are scared of guns
when we say the government compels
things people say oh well compulsion
well that's just like taxes right no and
somebody come into your house in the
middle of the night with a SWAT team
with a gun pointing it at you and
dragging you off to prison for not doing
what they want right that is what we are
facing right when it comes to the left
it's not what when we were such idiots
honestly we were constantly arguing
about whether our tax program is more
efficient than their tax program it's
not about efficiency Barack Obama gave
the right answer to the wrong question
right he get when he was asked in 2008
do you would you raise the capital gains
tax even if it means less revenue to the
government would you raise it he said
yes for purposes of fairness even if it
meant people were more impoverished even
if it meant people were more poor the
answer was yes for purposes of fairness
why because people don't speak the
language of poverty people don't speak
the language of efficiency people speak
the people don't speak Mitt Romney's 57
point tax plan you can't even name two
points on his 57 point tax plan people
speak the language of fairness and
justice and morality they want to think
that they're right and the other guy is
wrong they want to have a feeling of
them in many cases unearned moral
superiority based on their opposition to
things this is why all of everybody was
getting off ripping on Donald sterling
for being a crazy old racist coot
did they accomplish anything no but they
felt real good cuz they got to go around
telling all their friends that Donald
sterling was a racist old coot right
this is this is what they do so speak
their language in other words next time
they say something like I believe in the
minimum wage then you should say why
exactly is it that you want to put a gun
to the head of a business owner and
force them to pay something why is that
okay why isn't that violative of basic
principles of consent like you you know
you over here you like gay marriage
because you say that two men should be
able to Wed each other but those two men
shouldn't be able to do business with
each other in a mutually agreed
relationship so if instead of them
having sex they were actually just one
was signing a check to the other to
paint his car then you're saying that's
not okay and then you're gonna take a
gun and put it to the head of one of
them in order to make that happen
because you're a totalitarian
right this is the truth the left is
totalitarian you have to feel bad about
saying these things and when somebody on
that when you talk about the
inefficiencies of the left social
policies in the inner city who gives a
crap is it really I mean honestly that
no one in the inner city is thinking
about wow you know this really is not
very efficient what they're thinking is
they're a bunch of tea party Ku Klux
Klan is out there who are going to
invade their inner city and burn down
their houses why do they think that
because they're Democrats and apparently
some Republicans dad Cochran who
actually have been doing this sort of
stuff have been saying this sort of
stuff the answer to that is that the
real racists are and always have been
folks on the Left who wish to exploit
racial division in order to pay off
their cronies the reason the education
system sucks in the inner city is
because the left wants to pay off its
Union buddies at the expense of black
kids the reason that the left has not
done anything for the inner cities
despite years of dominance in Detroit
the reason is because they wanted the
violence and it is about intent it's not
about effect there's a really telling
point in the 2012 election cycle when
Bill Clinton was talking about Obama and
he said you know the difference you know
the difference between Obama and Mitt
Romney is that Romney is somebody who
who says the Barack Obama is in a really
poor job Barack knows he hasn't done a
great job but he feels really bad about
it this is an actual line right and and
people bought that because and the polls
show this right 80% of people 80% of
people thought that Mitt Romney cared
less about them than Barack Obama in
exit polls eighty percent that's a
majority of Republicans right but when
it came to policies they greeted Mitt
Romney but people don't vote with their
heads people vote with their hearts so
go after what people feel go after the
language of morality socialism is not a
good idea that went wrong and whenever
you hear Republicans or conservatives
say this it's because they have the IQ
of a kumquat socialism was a horribly
evil idea that went completely right it
went exactly as they thought it was
going to go this was the design from the
start socialism is a fundamentally
immoral evil unfair discriminatory and
disgusting system that violates off the
bat three of the Ten Commandments right
you don't steal God not government
and you shouldn't be jealous of your
neighbors ass right that's the that's
the in in the actual language correct no
not the Bill Clinton language so these
are these are the terms that we should
be speaking these are the terms that hit
young people because young people nobody
has the time to read all of the entire
editorial page of The Wall Street
Journal nobody does everybody's
attention span is five seconds long so
if you can't make people feel good about
being conservative make them feel really
really bad about feel about being
leftist you know why they deserve to
feel bad about being leftist they're
siding with an evil ideology then I got
to get my pulse down a little bit I
really want to thank you for an
informative exciting educational talk
that is enlightening for everybody I
have thank you I have two questions
hooked together but totally separate
because I don't want to be mistaken with
these questions number one you discussed
about the ideological foundings of
President Obama but I didn't recall
hearing you talk about what some
psychologists had talked about his
narcissism which is inability to see
where he's wrong
then the second question and separate
mm-hmm are you gonna run for office
someday as far as the first question you
know and and thank you for dealing the
questions I see now why you did that the
as far as the first question as to his
narcissism yes of course President Obama
is a dramatic narcissist most people who
run for office are which is why we're
dealing to the question the the the
first requirement of running for office
should be that you desperately do not
want to run for office that would be a
good start but as far as President Obama
his narcissism yes he's an egoist but
this goes along with the overweening
sense of self that comes along with a
nihilistic atheism resulting in his
ideology this is what the left is all
about it's all about narcissism it's
about your feelings doesn't matter if
that black kid in the inner city gets
shot in the face a couple of times all
that matters that you feel good about
what you say about the black kid who got
shot me in our city even if you didn't
say them or you're not gonna save his
neighbor leftism is all
narcissism it's all about helping
yourself because socialism is about
narcissism socialism is based on the on
the fundamental premise I'm breathing
I'm here feed me okay turns out that my
five month old baby is a socialist she
is right she's hungry I feed her she
poops I clean her right she's cuter than
the vast majority of socialists I know
but and the nice thing is at a certain
point I know she'll grow out of it I'm
like the rest of these idiots but but
socialism is all about selfishness it's
all about narcissism it's all about an
overweening sense of superiority based
on nothing you've ever done because
socialists by and large should not build
business businesses they don't make
people's lives better they don't
increase the the efficacy of government
they don't make people's prosperity
happen they don't do any of these things
they didn't build that in other words
but they take credit for that because it
makes them feel better so that's the
answer to the first question of course
he's an egotist of course Hillary
Clinton is an egotist of course Joe
Biden is a massive egotist because he's
not even smart and he's an egotist as
far as the second question would I would
I ever run for office there's too much
work to be done there's too much work to
be done so I could be like you know any
myriad number of Congress people who are
locked into battling over specific
provisions of 400-page laws I could be
locked into you know working on the
working on committees that debate all
day and do nothing and then are
overruled by the president of whim or I
could work to change the fundamental
ideology of the country and it won't
matter if Ted Cruz got elected or a
friend Paul got elected or Mike Pence or
Bobby or any of these folks if the
American people don't begin to
understand what America is all about and
we've lost that we've lost that we think
July 4th is about barbecues and more
than that we think it's about food-stamp
barbecues right we think that we think
that the American Founding is about the
idea that government is supposed to
provide for me we have all become
infantilized we are all adolescent in
our approach and it's interesting last
night slightly off topic but not really
last night I I was beginning to realize
for the thousandth time that since my
baby was born
she's completely destroyed my emotional
life because
I used to be the guy who is utterly
insensitive and callous and it was fun
and and last night I last night I'm
watching AMC because I'm an old man and
and on AMC and they're showing carousel
I'm big musical fan my dad writes
musicals I'm and so we're showing
carousel and it's about halfway through
the movie and my wife needs to do some
more so I flip off the TV and I turn on
YouTube and I watch and this is where
I'm not an old person and I've watched
the end of the I watched the end of
carousel on YouTube and so I'm sitting
there crying like a baby and and I'd
seen the musical I mean I've seen it and
many times performed and now I'm sitting
there crying and my wife looks at me and
she says why are you crying and I said
well I'm watching the end of carousels
that's what happens spoiler alert for
those who missed it in 1954 what happens
at the end of carousel is that Billy
Bigelow who has been killed halfway
through the musical he comes back and
he's supposed to and he's given this one
chance to tell his wife and his daughter
that he loves them so they can move on
and and so the end of the musical is him
saying I love you believe I loved you
Julie Julie's his wife and then he walks
off into the distance as they sing
you'll never walk alone right that's the
end of the musical so I tell my wife
this and of course she starts crying I
say you're not even watching it why are
you crying the point is this for those
of us who are responsible for those of
us who care about children have children
and care about the future recognize our
own mortality realize there's something
beyond ourselves
this is not a fight we can afford to
lose there is something beyond us the
left they're a bunch of adolescents they
don't care about the next generation in
fact I'm willing to bankrupt the next
generations they can have a good old
time right now they're willing to
redistribute all the wealth destroy
everything that we've created destroy
the greatest civilization in the history
of mankind
specifically to satiate their on their
own head in istic needs that's not what
we're about
and so in a way my daughter has
obviously taken the the piss out of me
but she has also changed she's deep in
what I already believed from something
that was in ideology into a Creed and a
way of life and for all of us who live
it it is a way of life that way of life
is under attack and the only way to
destroy the folks who are attempting to
attack us is to destroy them and destroy
them and destroy them and keep
destroying them and there is no
topia where they go away permanently
they won't the fight never ends
we can't afford to tire we can't afford
a falter if we do they will win but if
we fight back and we fight back strong
and we fight back smart and we recognize
the situation that we face I do believe
it with the grace of God we can win
thanks so much
[Applause]